the graphs of the linear function f of X
is equal to MX plus B and the
exponential function G of X is equal to
a times R to the X where R is greater
than zero pass through the points
negative 1 comma 9 so this is negative 1
comma 9 right over here and 1 comma 1
both graphs are given below so this very
clearly is the linear function it is a
line right over here and this right over
here is the exponential function so
right over here and given the given the
fact that this exponential function
keeps decreasing as X gets larger and
larger and larger it's a pretty good
hint that our are right over here they
tell us that R is greater than 0 but
it's a pretty good hint that R is going
to be between 0 and 1 the fact that G of
X keeps approaching it's getting closer
and closer and closer to 0 as x
increases but let's use the data they're
giving us the two points of intersection
to figure out what the equations of
these of these two functions are so
first we can tackle the linear function
so f of X is equal to M X plus V so they
give us two points we could use those
points first to figure out the slope so
our M R M right over here that's our
slope that's our change in Y over change
in X the rate and change of the vertical
axis with respect to the horizontal axis
so let's see between those two points
what is our change in X our change in X
if we were going from we're going from x
equals negative 1 to x equals 1 x equals
1 so we could think of it as we're
finishing at 1 we started at negative 1
so 1 minus negative 1 our change in X is
2 we see that right over there
and what about our change in Y well we
start at 9 let me do this in maybe
another color here just we start at 9
and we end up we end up at 1 so we end
up at 1 we started at 9 1 minus 9 is
negative 8 and just to be clear when X
was when X is
when X is 1 Y is 1 when X is negative 1
when X is negative 1 Y is 9 another way
to think about it the way I drew it
right over here we're finishing at x
equals 1 y equals 1 we started at x
equals negative 1 y equals 9 and so we
just took the differences we get
negative 8 over 2 which is equal to
negative 4 which is equal to negative 4
and so now we can write that f of X f of
X is equal to negative 4 negative 4
that's our slope times X negative 4
times X plus B and you could see that
slope right over here every every time
you increase every time you increase
your every time you increase your X by 1
I'm gonna be careful here I got a little
bit every time you increase your X by 1
you're decreasing your Y and here on the
x axis where we're marking off every
half so every time you increase your X
by 1 you are decreasing your Y you are
decreasing your Y by 4 there so that
makes sense that the slope is negative 4
so now let's think about what B is so
the figure out B we could use either one
of these points to figure out what F of
F given an X what f of X is and then we
can solve for B so let's say let's try
we know let's try F of let's try one
because one's a nice simple number so we
could write f of 1 which would be
negative 4 times 1 plus B and they tell
us that F of 1 is 1 is equal to 1 and so
this part right over here we could write
that as negative 4 plus B is equal to 1
and then we could add 4 to both sides of
this equation and then we get B is equal
to 5 so we get f of X is equal to
negative 4x plus 5 now does that make
sense that the y-intercept here is 5
well you see that right over here by
inspection you could all you could have
you could have guessed actually that the
y-intercept here is 5 but now we've
and maybe this was five point zero zero
zero zero or one or something but now we
know for sure it's negative 4x plus five
or another way you could have said it if
the slope is negative four
if this right over here is nine you
increase one in the x-direction you're
going to decrease four in the
y-direction that will get you to Y is
equal to five so that is the y-intercept
but either way we have figured out the
linear function now let's figure out the
exponential function so here we could
just use the two points to figure out
these two unknowns so for example let's
just try let's try this first point so G
of negative 1 which if we look at this
right over here would be a times R to
the negative 1 they tell us that G of
negative 1 is going to be equal to 9 G
of negative 1 is equal to 9 and so we
could write we could write this a times
R to the negative 1 that's the same
thing as a over R is equal to 9 or we
could multiply both sides by r and we
could say a is equal to 9 r now let's
use this other point this other point
they tell us they tell us the G of 1
which would be the same thing as a times
R to the first power or just a times R
that that is equal to that is equal to 1
or a times R is equal to 1 it's not can
we use this information right here a is
equal to 9 R and a times R is equal to 1
to solve for a and R well I have a
little system here it is a nonlinear
system but it's a pretty simple one we
could just take this a and substitute it
in right over here for a and so we would
get we would get 9r for a with this
first constraint tell us that a must be
equal to 9 r so 9 R instead of this
instead of writing an 8 here I'll write
9 R times R times R is equal to 1 or we
could write or we could write let me
scroll down a little bit we could write
9 R squared is equal to 1 divide both
sides by 9 R squared is equal to 1 over
9
and now to figure out are you could want
it you might want to take the plus the
positive and negative square root of
both sides but they tell us that R is
greater than zero so we can just take
the principal root of both sides and we
get R is equal to R is equal to
one-third and then we could substitute
this back into either one of these other
two to figure out what a is we know that
a is equal to nine times R so nine times
one-third a is equal to three so our
exponential function could be written as
G of X is equal to a which is three
times R which is one-third to the 1/3 to
the X